Anyone who has been in a crowded bar around
closing time would agree that the higher your
alcohol consumption, the more attractive you
seem to find whoever you happen to be flirting
with at last call.
Their smile is radiant; their eyes are sparkling-
everything about them is sexy, alluring and
irresistible.
However, if you were stone-cold sober, you
might not give them a second glance, and if
you get carried away and spend the night with
your new friend, you may wake up the next
morning and wonder just what the hell you
were thinking – and seeing.
This is called the Beer Goggles phenomenon,
and most of us that partake have fallen into
its trap to one degree or another.
The first question that comes to mind is whether
or not the individuals you’re looking at
are really more attractive to you or if your
judgment of things is simply being impaired
by alcohol.
So perhaps they really look the same to you
as later, but when drunk you just don’t
care, with alcohol increasing your desire
for sex and suppressing your inhibitions.
But it turns out, several studies done in
the last few decades are beginning to show
that it’s not all just being extra horny
and less picky.
For instance, a study done by St. Andrews
and Glasgow Universities found that “… men
and women who have consumed a moderate amount
of alcohol find the faces of members of the
opposite sex 25% more attractive than their
sober counterparts.”
Other studies have shown similar trends.
For instance, another study done at the University
of Bristol with 84 college students showed
that, on average, they rated people’s attractiveness
10% higher a mere 15 minutes after drinking
a moderate amount of alcohol, as little as
24 U.S. ounces of beer.
Further, the sex of the individual the students
looked at didn’t matter.
Yes, guys will rate guys more attractive and
women will rate women more attractive after
drinking too, regardless of their normal sexual
preferences.
Interestingly enough, this boost in attractiveness
is not universal.
In a study done at the University of Leicester
in 2011, it showed that adults actually find
the faces of 10 years old, less attractive
when drunk, not more as when looking at adult
faces.
Further, these individuals were able to accurately
judge the ages of the people whose faces they
were looking at pictures of.
So while attractiveness varied based on whether
one has been drinking or not, the ability
to judge age did not.
In any event, so if it’s truly not just
us lowering our standards, what’s going
on here to make other adult faces look more
attractive?
While further research still needs done, the
leading theory currently is that it has something
to do with bilateral symmetry.
This simply means that if a human body was
split down the vertical center, humans typically
find people more attractive the closer each
side of the individual is to being a mirror
of the other.
A series of studies, such as one done at the
London’s Roehampton University, suggest
that alcohol impairs our ability to perceive
asymmetry, and this could potentially be the
reason for people appearing more attractive
when one is under the influence.
The researchers described the experiment thusly:
We tested the hypotheses that acute alcohol
consumption decreases ability to detect asymmetry
in faces and reduces preference for symmetrical
faces over asymmetrical faces.
Twenty images of a pair of faces and then
20 images of a single face were displayed
on a computer, one at a time.
Participants were instructed to state which
face of each of the face pairs displayed was
most attractive and then whether the single
face being displayed was symmetrical or not.
Data were collected near campus bars at Roehampton
University.
Sixty-four self-selecting students who undertook
the study were classified as either sober
(control) or intoxicated with alcohol.
For each face pair or single face displayed,
participant response was recorded and details
of the alcohol consumption of participants
that day were also obtained.
What this boiled down to was that the sober
test participants were more drawn to people
with symmetrical faces, and were better at
picking them out, which supported the researchers’
hypothesis.
Further, intoxicated individuals were less
able to notice asymmetry.
An unexpected discovery was that males proved
better than females at determining whether
faces were asymmetrical or not.
It is theorized that this perhaps has something
to do with the fact that, in general, men
are more sexually stimulated visually than
women are, so whether consciously or not,
naturally pay more attention to such things.
The researchers concluded: “The reduced
ability of inebriated people to perceive asymmetry
may be an important mechanism underlying the
higher ratings of facial attractiveness they
give for members of the opposite sex and hence
their increased frequency of mate choice.”
Interestingly enough, it would seem that beer
goggles work both ways.
Not only will alcohol make those around you
become more attractive to you, it can also
turn you into a vision of epic awesomeness…
at least in your own mind.
(Where have you been your whole life?)
That said, the alcohol in this case isn’t
strictly necessary; you just need to think
you drank some.
Apropos, Laurent Begue at the Pierre Mendes-France
University conducted an experiment to explore
the phenomenon of The Drunker I Am, The Hotter
I Get Syndrome.
She asked 19 patrons in a French bar to rate
their attractiveness on a scale of one to
seven.
Their alcohol levels were then measured with
a breathalyzer test.
Not surprisingly, the participants who were
more biffed were also more full of themselves.
That was an extremely limited sample-size,
though, so as a follow-up, Begue performed
a balanced placebo test with 96 male volunteers.
They were told they were conducting market
research for fruit cocktail, and that half
of the group would be given an alcoholic drink
while the other would test the non-alcoholic
version.
After giving the booze enough time to work
its magic, all the guys recorded a fake advertising
spot for the fake beverage company.
Immediately after, they watched a playback
and rated their own wonderfulness.
As alluded to, not just those who had alcohol,
but those who believed they had alcohol, gave
themselves the best reviews.
Those who hadn’t had anything to drink – or
had but didn’t know that they had – were
the humblest among the bunch.
So what have we learned?
At least according to this study, in part
we feel happier and more attractive after
a few cocktails seemingly because we assume
that we will be in the first place.
There is a definite downside here though.
When a panel of impartial, sober judges took
a look-see at the advertising spots, the segments
done by the guys that gave themselves top
marks were voted the least appealing.
That, perhaps, explains why it’s so hard
to impress that hot number who just showed
up at the bar, when you’ve had more beers
than you can count.
So in the end, it would seem from the studies
to date that, while it’s not yet fully understood,
the “beer goggle” effect is probably real
beyond being partially influenced by the simple
fact that when your standards and inhibitions
are lowered while your libido is increased,
you’re going to partner up with those you
might not otherwise have.
But beyond that, attractiveness based on bilateral
symmetry may be coming into play as well,
literally making certain people seem more
attractive than they otherwise would to you.